ja das große bienensterben in den
letzten jahren das hat echt riesen
auswirkungen kurz und knapp gesagt
werden nämlich mit den bienen auch
millionen menschen sterben weil uns
nahrung fehlen wird was tun
ein deutsches forschungsteam macht jetzt
hoffnung denn sie haben ein gegenmittel
gegen den größten feind der bühne
entdeckt die varroa milbe wie also das
gegenmittel gegen den bienen parasiten
wirklich ob sich das bienensterben so
doch noch stoppen lässt jetzt sind klick
zum science und fiction bei uns gibt's
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nicht herzlich willkommen video bekommt
ihr weil ihr euch das thema über die
whatsapp gruppe auf klicks und science
fiction gewünscht habt herzlichen dank
dafür
den link dazu findet ihr in der video
beschreibung das aussterben der bienen
hätte katastrophale folgen für die
menschheit es gibt berechnungen nach
denen es durch entsprechende ausfälle
bei der ernte zu mehr als 1,4 millionen
todesfällen pro jahr kommen könnte
forschungsteams weltweit bleibt
vielleicht nicht mehr viel zeit um die
bienen zu retten experten und
expertinnen gehen davon aus dass bereits
in wenigen jahren einige bienen arten
ausgestorben sein werden die gründe den
insekten fehlt es an nahrung ihr
lebensraum wurde für die landwirtschaft
in beschlag genommen und auch der
einsatz von pestiziden gibt ihnen den
rest der größte feind der bienen ist
aber die varroa-milbe sie ist
tatsächlich in der lage innerhalb von
ein bis drei jahren ein komplettes
bienenvolk auszurotten und genau
deswegen könnte die entdeckung der
hohenheimer wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler ein echter durchbruch
sein
nach 25 jahren forschung sind sie nun
durch zufall auf ein gegenmittel
gestoßen es geht um die chemikalie
lithium chlorid die bislang
kurioserweise als enteisungsmittel
eingesetzt wird die vorteile sind enorm
ist verursacht weder resistenzen noch
rückstände zudem weiß das forschungsteam
darauf hin dass es wohl sowohl bienen
als auch für menschen unschädlich sei
lithium chlorid kann sehr einfach und
preiswert produziert werden und könnte
den bienen über das futter verabreicht
werden
dazu der leiter der landesanstalt für
bienenkunde peter rosenkranz lithium
chlorid kann man bienen in zuckerwasser
aufgelöst wird bei unseren versuchen
bereits geringe mengen der salzlösung
ausgereicht um innerhalb weniger tage
die auf den bienen auch sitzen bilden
abzutöten ohne nebenwirkungen für die
bienen und das sind alles wirklich
extreme vorteile wenn man bedenkt wie
imker bislang mit befallenen
bienenstöcken zu verfahren hatten die
wirklich aggressiven organischen säuren
oder chemischen anti milben mittel
hatten viele nebenwirkungen die jetzt
vielleicht geschichte sein könnten und
lithium chlorid ist keineswegs neues
wird bereits als trocknungs mittel und
enteisungsmittel eingesetzt denn es
handelt sich um ein in wasser leicht
lösliches lithium salz ärzte
verschreiben es patienten und
patientinnen mit depressionen ein
weiterer vorteil des wirkstoffs ist
seine verfügbarkeit dass sie zum chlorid
es gibt es in salzseen und laugen
genauso wie in heilquellen und das in
erstaunlich hoher konzentration nach
schätzungen gibt es weltweit vorräte von
mehr als 40 millionen tonnen
das ist auch als mittel gegen die varroa
milben taucht er kannte das deutsche
forschungsteam nur durch zufall in ihren
experimenten forschten sie zwar auch an
anti war mitteln doch eigentlich wollten
sie einen weitaus komplexeren ansatz
entwickeln um lebenswichtige gene der
bienen parasiten auszuschalten und ja
das sogenannte rna interferenz verfahren
funktioniert doch zeigte sich während
der experimente eine deutliche und
komplizierte und preisgünstige option um
die varroamilben zu bekämpfen denn in
der gegend mischung war offensichtlich
etwas drin was dem leben nicht bekamen
die bienen aber nicht störte
zwei jahre dauerte es dann auf den
missions bestandteil zu kommen der dafür
verantwortlich war
lithium chlorid eben in einer
pressemitteilung der universität
schreiben die verantwortlichen dass
bereits gespräche mit unternehmen
bezüglich einer produktentwicklung und
marktzulassungen laufen bis dahin stehen
wohl noch einige tests an beispielsweise
zur richtigen dosierung das
forschungsteam aus hohenheim warnt
ausdrücklich davor den stoff schon jetzt
vor seiner zulassung als
tierarzneimittel anzuwenden dazu peter
rosenkranz selbst versuche mit lithium
chlorid an den eigenen gegen völkern
wären
jetzigen zeitpunkt fahrlässig und
stellen darüber hinaus einen klaren
verstoß gegen das arzneimittelgesetz da
wo sie jetzt schon klar dass bienen
laufen die behandlung nicht überleben
vorsicht ist also geboten es ist also
noch etwas forschung nötig damit ein
mittel gegen die varroa mittel auf dem
markt kommen kann wir halten euch auf
dem laufenden wenn er kein video dazu
und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann abonniert kriegs um
auch auf englisch denn auch da gibt es
immer wieder videopremieren dafür
einfach hier draufklicken und hier geht
es weiter mit nano bott bekam reality
roberts in your body bis bald
hoffentlich auch auf dem englischen
kanal viel tun
stay tuned